[Music]
state of florida has just banned
teachers from talking to kindergartners
about their genitals the overwhelming
majority of americans support this
because
talking to kindergartners about their
genitals if you're not their parents is
a sex crime you are a sex criminal if
you do that but executives of the walt
disney corporation are panicked by this
they're so upset they've decided to ban
the words boy and girl from theme parks
but those executives do not speak for
all disney employees we are happy to
tell you jose castillo for example is a
current employee at disney he's running
for congress in florida's ninth
congressional district which includes
orlando and we're happy to have him
joining us tonight mr thanks so much for
coming on
um so you work at disney now you're
brave to do the show i have to say what
do you what is your view of disney's
support of talking to kindergartners
about their genitals
well first thank you talker for having
me on the show um i'll say this first
you know i don't speak for the walt
disney company but it's very evident
that the walt disney company does not
speak for me or for the solid majority
of uh disney customers who support this
as a matter of fact we're lucky to have
someone like governor desantis in
tallahassee that is speaking for us and
that's what i'm hoping to do to go speak
for the solid majority of disney
customers you know
my phone's been off the hook i've been
getting emails messages on social media
from
disney customers from all walks of life
all lines of business telling me thank
you for standing up uh we feel like we
don't have a voice and uh and we're glad
you're you're doing this so thank you
tucker for the opportunity
well yeah i mean people trust disney
with their children and a lot of people
who work at disney are good people like
you and and i'm sure most of your
co-workers so to sexualize children
is really a betrayal of the trust that
people have in disney units and it's
scary what's your sense as you campaign
in the commercial district around
orlando of how voters feel about this
well first let me i think i think
there's a huge misconception that
everyone here in you know central
florida and disney are you know raging
liberals and we're not you know we're
the problem is that we're a silent
majority uh the the small minority
that's very vocal uh there's a saying
squeaky wheel gets the grease and that's
what's happening you know this is a
company they're basically uh they're
capitalists right so they're listening
but they're listening to the people that
are more vocal and the solid majority us
we need to be more vocal we need to
stand up and that's why i'm here that's
why i hope to go to do in washington
stand up for the people for conservative
values
boy i sure hope you make it because what
you're saying is totally sensible it's
it's in line with what most people think
so that would be a victory for democracy
jose castillo thank you so much for
joining us tonight
tucker you you said that i was
courageous for being here a lot of
people said that you know i'm afraid of
losing my job i'm not afraid of losing
my job i'm afraid of losing my country
so you know that that's why i'm here i'm
running to be the next united states
representative for the people of central
florida thank you for the opportunity
tucker amen i hope i hope i see your
swearing in thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight